ich kann ihnen versprechen haben etwas
ganz tolles vor wir behandeln heute die
wohl zweitwichtigste theorie der
kausalität die es gibt in der geschichte
der philosophie vielleicht auch die
drittwichtigste aber eine der
wichtigsten und wenn sie diese theorie
heute verstehen die frage ob es
überhaupt beziehungen ist aber diese
behandlung der kausalität verstehen die
wir heute behandeln werden dann haben
sie sehr gute grundlagen um alle
weiteren theorie nahm ebenfalls zu
verstehen bevor wir jetzt aber auf den
theoretiker der heutigen sitzung zu
sprechen komme ich die noch mal eine
kurze wiederholung macht der thematik
die weder letzten sitzung behandelt
hatten nämlich aristoteles hatten sie da
noch rückfragen auch auf basis der
zusammenfassung die sie von mir herum
geschickt bekommen haben oder die sie
auf der fibo graafschap vorfinden können
haben sie dann noch fragen dazu noch mal
ganz kurz wiederholend haben wir schon
oft gemacht können wir noch mal kurz die
vier ursachen nennen nach aristoteles
einfach mal zu rufen und vielleicht auch
in einer bestimmten logik das möchte mit
ihnen mich noch mal kurz diskutieren ich
habe da in dieser zusammenfassung
versucht das hat glaube ich noch nie
jemand gemacht ich kenne jedenfalls
nichts dazu dass man versuche diese vier
ursachen aber nicht nur so willkürlich
oder wie kann sagen würde rhapsodisch
anzunehmen als einfach so aufzählen es
gibt halt die dd dd
es gibt viele man kann sich auch fragen
warum gibt es genau 4
ja warum ich fünf oder können wir nicht
auch manche ursachen
unter zurückführen das ist auch noch ein
wichtiger punkt ich glaube sie brauchen
es mir gar nicht sagen ich weiß sie
wissen diese vier ursachen haben wir
jetzt parat das ist ja auch nicht weiter
schwierig aber wenn wir jetzt uns das
noch einmal ganz kurz vergegenwärtigen
in welcher reihenfolge aristoteles diese
vier ursachen aufzählt ist es doch
dankenswert denke ich oder ein bisschen
merkwürdig sagt hier unten
das ist also unten ist die stoff ursache
stoffes seien die die basis dann sagte
kommt was kommt danach formsache
und dann sagt er kommt die wirkung sache
und dann kommt ganz oben die zweck
ursache
schon jetzt kann man sich fragen ja gut
verhalten die sich alles so dass wir sie
so also so einfach aufzählen können oder
liegt da nicht eine andere logik
zugrunde und meine these war dann dir
das haben wir uns gemeinsam auch ein
bisschen herausgearbeitet dass man also
stoff und form ursache eigentlich auf
dieselbe ebene setzen muss es war also
meine these körper kann man noch mal
kurz diskutieren also ich würde sagen
wir nehmen die darunter schreiben wir
vorm ursachen warum schreibe ich dir
jetzt neben die stoff ursache haben
seitdem als ich hoffe sache kommt zuerst
würde ich schon sagen dann kommt die
form ursache warum schreibe ich dir
jetzt auf dieselbe ebene was für gründe
könnte es dafür geben
genau wurde bald stoff und form ursache
irgendwie beteiligt sind gleichermaßen
beteiligt sind an der konstitution eines
gegenstandes oder eines objekts
also wenn wir jetzt hier eine statue
bauen dann haben wir den stoff das ist
jetzt zum beispiel irgendwie ein stein
marmor stein und wir haben die form in
die der stein gebracht wird also die
beiden verhalten sich irgendwie
komplementär zueinander könnte man sagen
es wird es war meine these also beide
wenn die zusammengebracht werden dann
bilden die einst in holon das habe ich
jetzt aber auch kurz erklärt was es ist
es also ein zusammen ganzes in holland
also holz heißt ganz und schönheit
zusammen also da wenn form und stoff
zusammen sind haben wir eine einheit
eine abgerundete sache sozusagen ein
gegenstand der ausformung stoff besteht
genau es gibt auch genau bei aristoteles
ist es so dass er sagt die form
existieren nicht unabhängig von der
materie
die frage ist wie sich mit gott verhält
bei platon ist es so das wissen sie alle
dass die formeln oder die ideen sagt
platt und dass die unabhängig existieren
können von irgendwas anderen bei
aristoteles ist es so dass die nicht
unabhängig existieren können die form
die form muss gott ist eine ausnahme
muss man jetzt diesen diese thematik
muss man es mal außen vor lassen aber
die normale und theologie bei
aristoteles sagt dass form die form als
solchen eu unabhängig von einer materie
einem stoff existieren kann
deswegen sind form und nach als lottes
form und stoff auch nicht eigentlich
entitäten die unabhängig existieren
sondern sie sind komplementär
sie sind aufeinander verwiesen sie sind
auch gar nicht so sehr teile sondern sie
sind eher moment müsste man sein moment
im moment bedeutet sie hat sind
eigentlich eine logische sache eine
logische angelegenheiten momente einer
sache aspekte würden auch gehen aber ist
vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu schwach
also moment und jetzt war meine
vermutung aber darüber kann man noch
diskutieren
sie müssen zusammengebracht werden und
jetzt in form im beispiel dieses
künstlers der diese statue baut dann
bringt er sie zusammen mit der wirkung
sache an sowie werden beide momente sage
jetzt mal seinen ganzen vereint durch
die wirklichkeit
es hat die eben beides aufeinander
bezieht also der die form wird in den
stoff eingearbeitet und den marmor stein
das wäre so meine these kann man
diskutieren
das war also sagt sie verhalten sich so
zueinander die wirklichkeit die bildet
die einheit ermöglicht überhaupt die
einheit von form und schnell fahren und
dann kann man sich fragen wie hängt das
jetzt dann wie hängt die zweck ursache
damit zusammen dass idee wie man die
zweck ursache dann noch hier reinbringen
kann dieses dieses dieses muster wie
könnte man jetzt die zweck ursache dann
noch anordnen wo kommt die zwick ursache
ins spiel
ich will erst mal zu sagen dass
einfachen waren und der vier elemente
wasser
[Musik]
ok und da ist auch schon da
wasser und ebenfalls okay gut würden sie
dann die zweck ursache mit dem feuer in
verbindung bringt das feuer hat ja auch
so was ihr fluide ist als etwas nicht so
greifbar ist etwas transzendente sag
jetzt mal so ganz wagen interessante
these b noch nicht draufgekommen dass
man das auf diese vier elemente zion
geführt unter gute ideen aber sieht die
frage wie verhält sich dann die zweck
ursache zu diesen drei ursachen wie
könnte ich jetzt versuchen nach diesem
modell will mit meinen zusammenhang
bringen wollen die zweck ursache hier
noch irgendwie einzubeziehen wir haben
jetzt ja eigentlich mit der wirkung
sache schon die entsteht das ding
vollständig vorliegen
wie könnte ich jetzt da wenn sie jetzt
mal ein beispiel des künstlers bleiben
wie könnte ich jetzt da noch die zweck
ursache bei einer statue noch irgendwie
mit reinbringen haben sie die wie könnte
ich zweck ursache hier noch mit
einbeziehen
überlegen sie mal sie haben jetzt eine
vollständig konstituierten gegenstand
eine statue aus marmor form und stoff
ursache sind als momente an gewesen
retrospektiv wie sie sagen sie sind
schon am werk gewesen dadurch ist jetzt
der gegenstand verhandeln und wie kann
ich jetzt die finale ursache also dass
wut zu wie kann ich das jetzt da noch
mit in verbindung bringen der gegenstand
ist doch schon vollständig vorliegen als
die frage ist wozu brauche ich noch die
frage nach dem wozu eines dinges wenn es
doch schon ist
also genau also wie würden sich dann
bescheiden
die zusagen die betrachtungen erste
intensive betrachtung also
dementsprechend rechtliche betrachtung
macht aus den standorten okay bei apple
und dann
erst dadurch also dass der künstler
kombi ist dieser drei dinge bewusst
geworden des stoffes in der gesamten und
zweckmäßig den start
genau da waren noch mehrere meldungen
sieg
allerdings erst möglich dass dieses
thema erstmal nur bei jungen machen
passiert ist so ok nicht mehr menschen
also die natur alles okay wir uns sagen
die zweck ursache dieser masterplan so
was meinen sie wahrscheinlich und dieser
masterplan nachdem überhaupt irgendwas
in gang gesetzt wird nachdem überhaupt
etwas
ja wobei immer ein bisschen wirklichkeit
haben wir ja schon mit der wirkung also
da tritt ja schon trotz also stoffe ist
ja sagen die möglichkeiten die die
potenz und die formel so die
aktualisierung die bringt die
wirklichkeiten kann und wenn wir jetzt
und das verwirklichen der form also das
einarbeiten sozusagen der form in den
stoff
ebenso ist die möglichkeit dass man das
funktionieren okay okay also ok ok als
es sozusagen die möglichkeit der
wirklichkeit meist die möglichkeit der
verwirklichung ist das okay und dann
wäre das hier die wirklichkeit der
wirklichkeit als ich noch die
möglichkeit der wirklichkeit
okay da war noch eine meldung ist so gut
möglich ist sie hatten sich noch glaube
ich mir die kommilitonen gleich daneben
sie haben sich auch gemeldet
das geht in die richtung des
kommilitonen die sie diese wozu
eigentlich das ganze
wozu sollte ich jetzt hier überhaupt
mich an die arbeit machen möglicher ich
dachte es jetzt so aber jetzt geht in
ihre richtung
überlegen sie mal so eine statue ist ja
ein gebrauchsgegenstand eine statue ist
ja nicht nur einfach ein vorliegendes
objekt nach aristoteles gibt's fast ich
bin nicht ganz sicher aber einig hat
alles seinen zweck naja diese generelle
theologie das ja diese diese auffassung
dass alles ein zweck hat und im falle
einer statue wird dieser zweck besonders
greifbar weil die statue die stellen wir
irgendwohin die statue stellen wir zum
beispiel nicht irgendwie ein ein ort wo
es keine menschen gibt die statue
stellen wir nicht auf dem mond oder so
vielleicht schon aber da müssen wir
immer einen grund angeben also die
statue die transportiert bedeutung die
statue steht auch nicht alleine für sich
sondern die statue steht in einem
kontext zu anderen kultur gegenstimmen
ich würde mal sagen dass man die statue
als ein kultur gegenstand auch ansehen
kann und dass die statue im kontext von
anderen kultur gegenständen steht und
wie sie steht und anlässlich welches
ereignisse sie hingestellt wird solche
fragen dieser den kontext betreffen die
würde ich sagen gehen in die indy zweck
ursache auch mit rein das ist jetzt mein
versuch
das zu erklären also es ist größer man
könnte eigentlich sagen mit der wirkung
sache ist doch schon alles getan
wieso sollte ich jetzt noch nichts zur
sache dass sich sehr dass er praktisch
schwarzen peter hat eigentlich ja nur
menschliche eigentlich abgeraten
auch dieses früheren sprache die sprache
sehr wenig genommen wird sondern regen
möglich
das wahnsinnig ganz genau weil man ja
häufig sagt die römer seien ja noch
praktisch als die griechen gewesen also
normalerweise gelten ja die alten
griechen als die theoretiker als sie die
abstrakt denken und die römer hier als
die pragmatiker
deswegen bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher
ist einfach die frage wenn wir kultur
habe oder wenn wir orientierung haben
dann fragen wie immer nach einem grund
warum es so ist und dieser grund ist
nicht nur ein grund der jetzt einzelne
gegenstände betrifft sondern einen
generellen grund also man könnte das
sogar auch er mit dem griechischen
idealismus zusammenbringen gar nicht so
sehr mit dem pragmatismus genau die
andere richtung also sagen sie haben
eigentlich recht aber ich würde sagen es
ist ihr dem idealismus geschuldet war
dass man selbst wenn man jetzt
gegenstand der hut und erklären kann wie
sie als einzelne gegenstände da die na
das war ja ein warum sind sie jetzt
überhaupt da einen größeren kontext
bekommen sie erst ihre bedeutung so wird
es verstößt
ja durchaus ja auch perfektionismus
sowas ist denke ich da auch angelegt die
natur ist ja nach der griechischen
auffassung einen kosmos schreibst umhin
ein kosmos und ein kosmos ist ein sehr
hoch seien sehr geordneten zustand ein
ort geordneter zustand die ordnung
bedeutet dass die dinge wie sie sich in
der welt befinden nicht einfach
irgendwie so da sind sein dass sie wohl
gefühlt sind also dass sie aus einem
gewissen grund dort sind wo sie sind und
dass dieser grund gut ist dass es auch
noch nicht gefunkt und es ist schön also
die natur ist auch noch schön und da wo
die schönheit ins spiel kommt da haben
wir die zweckmäßigkeit und spielen schön
ist das wenige was ein zweck erfüllt was
also wohl gefühlt ist was harmonisch das
ist schön und das ist auch zugleich nach
der zweck ursächlichkeit zb
wohlproportionierte dass alles seine
richtigkeit hat das ist kommt er noch
dazu ohne dieser diesem diesem
theologischen denkens und manifestiert
sich bestimmt so eine art von idealismus
im weitesten sinne jetzt gesprochen
als die ästhetik ist es sehr guter
hinweis die ästhetik ja da braucht man
nicht nur jetzt eine bestimmte epoche
ins auge nehmen sondern generell wenn
fragen nach schönheit und so aufgeworfen
werden dann hat immer die theologie dort
was zu bedeuten
okay das also meinen vorschlagen wir
können darüber reden also denkt eben
immer dass man sagt wenn man jetzt von
gewissen ursachen spricht dann muss man
sich immer fragen welche verhältnis
stehen sie zueinander
wir werden jetzt aber in der zukunft
oder eigentlich ab jetzt sogar nur noch
diese wirkung sache hier ins zentrum
stellen nur noch die wirkung sache
spielt jetzt eine rolle
andere ursachen werden für uns vorerst
jetzt keine rolle mehr spielen und zwar
wir werden das jetzt gleich sehen
mit diesem netten herren hier den sie
jetzt hier sehen david hume und der hat
eine schrift verfasst mit dem titel
traktat über die menschliche natur da
hat der gute mann erst 27 jahre alt das
müssen sie sich mal vorstellen mit 27
hatte dieses tolle werk geschrieben und
wir lesen daraus den zweiten abschnitt
über die wahrscheinlichkeit und die
vorstellung von ursache und wirkung
und jetzt haben wir natürlich uns wieder
ein paar
leitfragen überlegt ich sage ihnen aber
noch mal ganz kurz was zu debattieren
also david hume war ein schotte und es
gibt seien drei berühmte britische jetzt
mal britannien als die einheit dieser
verschiedenen nationen dort sieht es
gibt eben die schottische aufklärung es
ist die zeit der aufklärung und die zeit
des wissens empirismus bedeutet dass man
verschiedene fragen vor allem
erkenntnistheoretische fragen also
fragen nach dem was ich wissen kann
durch bezug auf die erfahrung zu klären
versuchen
aber auch andere fragen werden durch
bezug auf die erfahrung vor allem
versucht zu klären und empirismus steht
wie sie alle wissen im gegensatz
tendenziell zum rationalismus ist jetzt
natürlich ganz grobe kategorisierungen
der rationalismus
bei der frage nach dem was wir wissen
können ist der primäre bezug nicht
unsere erfahrung mit unsere sinnesorgane
sondern unser denken selbst da ist zum
beispiel leibnitz ein guter kandidat
dafür
und auch ohne descartes sie kennen alle
dieses cogito diese coppito reflexion
der ecartec wenn ich etwas vertrauen
kann wenn etwas mich nicht täuschen kann
dann ist es mein denken beziehungsweise
mein selbstbewusstsein
die sinne können mich gerade täuschen
dass ich jetzt da in der ferne glaube
einen eckigen turm zu sehen mit einem
eckigen grundriss und dabei stellt sich
heraus beim näherkommen hatten runden
grundriss aus der ferne kann ich das
nicht objektiv beurteilen deswegen sagt
eckhard er den sinnen kann ich nicht
trauen sondern ich muss man denken und
glauben schenkt und der empirismus
vertritt die genau entgegengesetzte
auffassungen dasjenige was die basis
oder der anfang allen wissens ist ist
nicht unser denken und selbstbewusstsein
sondern die erfahrung die uns unsere
sinne vermitteln
und da steht eben david hume als ein
schottischer vertreter dieses
aufgeklärten empirismus in einer
tradition von anderen denken zum
beispiel von john block und lockt ist
jetzt der engländer unter diesen dreien
empirischen der auch noch vor david hume
gelebt hat und john bock hat ebenso den
anfang gemacht diese im puristischen
erkenntnistheorie der hat sich dann
gedanken gemacht über die rolle der
vorstellungen diron der eindrücke also
wir haben erst eindrücke das sind die
direkten einwirkungen das schon durch
wirkung sache von außen auf uns
einwirken der sinne oder
sinnesinformationen strömen auf uns ein
und wenn wir dann dieses eindrücke
verarbeiten oder abspeichern dann
bekommen wir davon vorstellungen und mit
den vorstellungen können wir dann weiter
operieren und abstrakter werden aber
alles hat seinen ausgang in der
sinnlichen erfahrung da haben wir noch
george buckley barkley ist ein ihre also
der gehört auch noch mit dieses trio und
er hat auch eine tendenziell in
puristischer erkenntnistheorie vertreten
auch wenn sich bei barclay dann noch
etwas mehr idealismus hinein mischt wir
lesen jetzt aber die revision der auch
der jüngste dieser
drei britische touristen ist und
vielleicht auch der bedeutendste von
allen dreien und jetzt haben wir uns ein
paar fragen überlegt also welche
bedingungen müssen gegeben sein damit
man nach juni eine kausalität relation
annehmen kann
das ist also eine spannende frage ist
nun geht's eben wie sie sehen anhand
dieser dieses kapitel ziehen geht es um
die wahrscheinlichkeit und vor allem das
ist jetzt unser punkt die vorstellung
von ursachen für die vorstellung ist
jetzt nicht nur unsere idee die wir
davon haben
man könnte auch sagen unser begriff von
vorstellung von ursachen wirkungen
seine vorstellung war jetzt im sinne
dieser empirischen erkenntnistheorie
eben das schwache abbild von möglichen
eindrücken die wir dafür gemacht haben
dass uns auskunft über die
ursächlichkeit die kausalität in der
welt also vorstellungen denke ich
sollten wir nicht jetzt nur so verstehen
im schwachen sind eine idee oder ein
gedanke so eine vorstellung ist die
frage haben wir eine repräsentation als
eine geistige repräsentation von
ursächlichkeit oder kausalen beziehungen
die in der welt faktisch existieren und
die uns über die sinne vermittelt wird
das ist die frage
also die erste frage ist wie gesagt
welche bedingungen müssen gegeben sein
damit man nach jung überhaupt eine
kausalität relation annehmen kann dann
eine ganz spannende frage meine
lieblingsfrage immer welche art von
entitäten sind nach jung ursachen und
wirkungen
achten sie mal ganz genau jetzt darauf
wie ich jung von ursache und wirkung
spricht was er dazu sagen sagte es sind
ereignisse sind prozesse es sind dinge
was sagt er dazu sind es features sind
es situationen solche fragen wir uns
stellen und dann kann man sich fragen
welchen und theologischen als es einst
mäßigen und systemischen
erkenntnistheoretischen status hat nach
jugend die kausalität relation also
immer die frage gibt es überhaupt
kausalitäten
oder ist die annahme von kausalität
nicht nur so eine fiktion so eine bloß
idee eine bloße hilfskonstruktion die
wir annehmen müssen wie wir in die natur
hineinlegen diese idee obwohl es der
natur oder in der erfahrungswelt
eigentlich so was wie qualität gar nicht
gibt und jetzt habe ich schon
vorweggenommen
in diese richtung wird der wirt jungen
tatsächlich argumentieren er wird also
die kausalität relation sehr stark
problematisieren indem er sie nicht nur
ökologisch oder auch logisch betrachtet
das ist nämlich auch eine frage die auch
noch mit aufgenommen aufnehmen hätte
können welchen logischen status die
auslandsredaktion hat aber er betrachtet
sie eben auch zum ersten mal eigentlich
richtig ganz strikt jedenfalls unter
erkenntnistheoretischen gesichtspunkt
normalerweise würde man sagen die frage
nach die qualitäten logische oder eine
ontologische angelegenheit er sagt nein
es ist vor allem psychologische
angelegenheit die unsere erkenntnis der
welt betrifft und da habe ich ja schon
genannt welche logik hat die kausalität
redaktion
das wollen wir auch noch fragen ok haben
sie noch andere fragen gehabt bei der
lektüre oder noch andere fragen
dass sie an david hume herantragen
wollen bevor wir jetzt auf den ersten
text gehen
ich weiß nicht was die eindruck war aber
ich habe den eindruck gehabt dass der
text war im gegensatz zu dem von
aristoteles sehr gut verständlich
ja das ist natürlich eine übersetzung
wir könnten natürlich jetzt auch den
englischen text lesen aber mal weniger
philologie betreiben wollen zu
diskutieren wollen
vor allem die man jetzt halt noch mal
die deutschen text ich kann den ihn aber
gerne auch noch digital zugänglich
machen ok wenn sie also da keine
weiteren fragen hand gehen wir einfach
mal einen text lesen davor also alle
arten von denk vorgängen bestehen
lediglich in einer aufeinander beziehung
von vorstellungen und einem auffinden
der entweder veränderlichen oder
unverändert
relation in den zwei oder mehr
gegenstände zueinander stehen
eine solche aufeinander beziehung von
gegenständen können wir vollziehen
entweder wenn beide gegenstände in sind
gegenwärtig sind wohl wenn keiner
familien oder wenn nur einer den sinn
gegenwärtig ist wenn beide gegenstände
und mit ihnen die dazwischen ihnen
bestehende beziehung den sind
gegenwärtig sind sondern wenn dies
vielmehr eine wahrnehmung als einen
denkt vorgang eine bestätigung des
denkvermögens oder überhaupt eine
tätigkeit im eigentlichen sinne findet
in solchem falle nicht statt der vorgang
besteht ledig in der passiven aufnahme
der eindrücke durch die organe der
sinnesempfindungen hier sehen sie also
david holmes behandlung der kausalität
thematik ist innerhalb des kontextes
einer im puristischen erkenntnis zu
verorten
also die frage was ursachen wie das
wirklich sind die betrachtet er unter
dem gesichtspunkt der allgemeineren
erkenntnistheorie von bezügen von und
das ist jetzt ganz interessant wird die
frage nach der ontologie von
gegenständen
das sind gegenstand das ist also ganz
allgemein die englische übersetzung wäre
wahrscheinlich objects also objekt ich
denke das ist die richtige besetzung
und jetzt möchte ich mal kurz seine
erkenntnistheorie bisschen skizzieren
dass wir die hier als einen hintergrund
ansetzen können vor dem dann die
thematik nach der kausalität jetzt hier
ist also behandelt wird also jetzt sagt
er hier gegenstände können den sinnen
gegenwärtig sein oder sie können den
sinnen nicht
gegenwärtig seien
genau so
wir haben jetzt hier zwei möglichkeiten
wir haben den eindruck 1 und eindruck 22
das kann jetzt jeder beliebige
sinneseindruck sein das kann jetzt zb
sein dass sie ein schmerzempfinden im
rechten daumen
es ist ein eindruck eines sinnes oder
dass sie von links aus dem linken ohr
einen ton mit der frequenz 380 herz das
ist ein eindruck ja ganz genau und das
ist ein interessantes anders als ein
gegenstand dhs sagt ein eindruck und da
kommt jetzt die unter logi wieder ins
spiel
ein eindruck ist ein gegenstand es
entgegen stimmen das ist schon mal sehr
seltsam
also sagt offensichtlich also die art
wie sich uns die sinnlichkeit also die
erfahrung präsentiert hat an sich schon
objektiven charakter in einer gewissen
zeit weil sie das heißt jetzt nicht dass
wir alle dieselbe denselben eindruck
machen dass wir alle die welt genauso
sehen aber aus unserer perspektive so
wie wir die welt wahrnehmen ist die
wahrnehmung objektiv also ist geformt
geformtes jetzt ein bisschen
problematisch aber sie hat mit
einheitlichkeit
sie hatten objekt heißt ja auch ist es
abgrenzbar wir können verschiedene
eindrücke die wir haben mit unseren
verschiedenen sinnesorgan voneinander
abgrenzen und isolieren und das meint
jetzt gegenstand oder objekte
zb kann man sagt ja dass diese region
auf die gegenstände zu finden
die wirklichkeit war genau also sie
haben natürlich gut jetzt schon voraus
griffen auf kant kant wird sagen und
auch viele andere philosophen damit wir
überhaupt objekte fahren köln muss immer
schon ein ding vorgang vorhanden sein
oder etwas apriori zwar selbst nicht
gegenstand erfahrung ist als
gegenständlichkeit die tatsache dass
etwas als abgegrenzt entität vorliegt
ist nichts was wir aus der natur selbst
ziehen können in der erfahrung sind dann
muss noch von uns eine leistung mit
hinzukommen sagt kant dem fall jugend
macht die annahme dass es etwas von der
natur oder von der sinneswahrnehmung
hergegeben es gibt und das hat man dann
aus kritischer perspektive den mythos
des gegebenen genannt ich schreibe sind
übersetzung von englisch der mythos des
gegeben also dass man wie jung glaubt
auf basis der sinneserfahrung objekte so
gegeben ich habe jetzt da so ein ton so
ein akustisches ins alte rom und der ist
als objekt gegeben ich habe diesen
visuellen sind es eindruck ich sehe hier
diesen gegenstand in dieser
gegenständlichkeit und diese
gegenständlichkeit ist so geben
das ganze land war kant wird sagen damit
wir überhaupt etwas als gegenstand
erkennen können zb als substanz zu sagen
können dieser tisch hat diese
eigenschaft und diese farben und sie
sagen können dieser tisch hat die
eigenschaft diese struktur das etwas
substanz ist mit eigenschaften
es ist nichts was in der natur der
sinnes erkenntnis vorliegt sind diese
gliederung in unterteilung von substanz
und
eigenschaft oder attribut oder akzidenz
dass es etwas was nicht aus der natur
stammt sondern aus uns selbst jung macht
diese unterscheidung nicht sagt es gibt
die gegenstände in der natur wenn wir
uns jetzt mal überlegen wie es beim ton
ist wenn sie jetzt da was hören dann
finde ich eigentlich kann man nicht
jetzt da nicht kritisieren weil oder
nicht mit guten argumenten kritisieren
wenn ich jetzt hier für verizon kunden
einen ton höhere mit einer stabilen
frequenz ganz homogen ja dann habe ich
da einen gegenstand der wahrnehmung
genauso wenig einen total homogenen grün
eindruck haben ja wenn ich jetzt an die
wand schauen oder mir hier was
eingespielt wird die meine sehnerven
gereizt werden
das ist total homogen sind eindruck
entstehen dann habe ich da einen total
homogenen naja ich weiß nicht was
gegenstand nehmen soll aber eindruck
geben ein total homogen 1 und die ist
gegeben natürlich ist die gegeben
schwierig wird es eben wenn wir von
dingen sprechen wenn ich sagt ich sehe
da ein stuhl
aber dann war der stuhl hat diese
eigenschaften und in dem ich die
unterscheidung von substanz und
eigenschaft mache da gehe ich über die
bloße sinneserfahrung hinaus weil ich
sehe hier nur ich habe hier eigentlich
nur wenn ich den stuhl betrachter hier
die stühle habe ich eigentlich mit dem
eindruck so gelb gelb eindruck bisschen
silber eintritt ein bisschen schwarz von
abschnitt anordnen wenn ich mich bewege
im raum dann sehe ich den stuhl mit
denselben farben aber es kommt
vielleicht noch eine farbe hinzu die
jetzt nicht mehr verdeckt ist usw also
die unterstellung dass ich einen stuhl
see mit diesen eigenschaften ist schon
eine voraussetzung die ich mache da
bringe ich schon etwas hinein in die
bloße sinnes erkenntnisse dass ich sag
stuhl in dem sinne dass hat eine
substanz und er hat eigenschaften
ich sehe nicht die substanz des stuhls
ich sehe auch nicht seine eigenschaften
dass er eigenschaften hat ich sehe nur
oder ich nehme nur verschieden
sinnliches war und wenn ich ihn anfasst
dann habe ich den eindruck dass es haut
den den haptischen eindruck von härte
aber im grunde genommen kann ich nicht
sagen dass der studie substanz ist sagt
jetzt ja auch nicht er geht jetzt hier
wirklich nur von bloßen sehr simplen im
sinnes eindrücken aus und jetzt können
natürlich auch sagen
wir können jetzt davon abstrahieren
wir können auch nicht bloß die
gegenstände müssen jetzt nicht bloß
konkrete lebens sein sondern sie können
auch nicht den sinn gegenwärtig seien
und was denken sie was wäre das dann
wenn ich jetzt hier wenn dieser eindruck
nicht mehr den sinnen gegenwärtig sind
was wird dann aus diesen eindrücken die
sie nicht mehr gegenwärtig sind aber ich
sie dennoch reflektiere was habe ich
dann aus den eindruck gemacht
genaue erinnerungen oder vorstellungen
ich habe die vorstellung gebildet und
nach der videos sind vorstellungen
schwache abbilder der eindrücke
vorstellung 1 und vorstellungen sollen
zwei so das ist die logik und mit diesen
vorstellungen wird dann weiter operiert
wie kann ich aufeinander beziehen
natürlich sind diese eindrücke auch
schon in einer beziehung und die frage
die sich jetzt stellt ist können wir
qualität oder ursächlichkeit und wirkung
so verstehen dass sich steht den
eindrücken in ihrem bezug zueinander
analysieren also kann sich aus der
konstellation von eindrücken oder dann
schwachen abbildung und vorstellungen
kann sich daraus der begriff der
kausalität verständlich machen
das ist die frage und anders gefragt
kann ein eindruck 1 die ursache von
einem eindruck zwei sein dass die frage
können wir aus dieser basis von
sinneserfahrung von erkenntnis können
wir auf diese erkenntnis basis mit
diesem verfahren des empirismus können
wir auf dieser basis kausalität
verständlich machen das ist sagen die
leib frage die sich jetzt david hume
vorsitzt und vielleicht kommen sie
gleich drauf vielleicht auch nicht also
man kann jetzt schon ein bisschen weiter
denken und überlegen ja fassen denn
eindrücke will ich für
die eindrücke habe die aufeinander
folgen oder auch nicht
aufeinanderfolgend gleichzeitig sind
kann ich mit so einer konstellation von
entitäten oder gegenstimmen kann ich
damit überhaupt prinzipien dieses
komplexe konzept von kausalität je
erschließen angemessene per ist ich kann
ich das konzept von kausalität empirisch
analysieren
bis die frage genau da kommen wir gleich
drauf sie haben verliebt mir kommen dann
noch drauf also ich wollte damit nur
sagen die zeitlichkeit spielt eine rolle
also genau ja
genau genau wir müssen eigentlich sagen
eindruck 1 oder wir können auch sagt
eindruck eindruck derart beeindruckt
dass tipps oder derart b und dann müssen
wir hier noch im index weiter 1 1 tragen
nämlich t1 und t2 so nah es könnten es
könnte sein dass vorkommnisse zwei
vorkommnisse derselben art von eindruck
das nennt man im englischen dann ein ton
können also type ist die art des
eindrucks zb ein gelb eindruck eine
visuelle eindruck vielleicht und ein
token wäre dann ein bestimmter typ ich
weiß ich hab das ist genau so trifft
jedenfalls man kann sagen ein eindruck
der altar als eine visuelle eindruck der
zum zeitpunkt t1 erfolgt und eine
visuelle eindruck der zum zeitpunkt des
2 wir müssen ja noch unterscheiden
zeitlicher das mitteilt und trocken
genau hinschaut und weiß jetzt gerade
nicht das lesen wir weiter halten wir
dieses fest zu dürfen wir keine unserer
beobachtungen betreffend die identität
und die beziehungen von raum und zeit
als denk vorgang aufpassen denn der
geist kann weil keiner derselben über
das hinausgehen was den sinne nur
mittelbar gegenwärtig ist er kann
insbesondere keine über die
sinneswahrnehmung hinausgehende existenz
der wirklichen existenz
machen muss wahrscheinlich heißen nur
die ursächlichkeit schließt eine
verknüpfung in sich die so beschaffen
ist dass wir aus der existenz oder
tätigkeit eines gegenstandes die
gewissheit schöpfen können es sei ihr
eine andere existenz oder tätigkeit
gefolgt oder vorangegangen
die beiden anderen beziehungen nehme ich
die identität und die von raum und zeit
die hier oben genannt hatte die beiden
anderen beziehungen können über einem
über die wahrnehmung hinausgingen
erkennt stets nur soweit dient als sie
den gedanken der ursächlichkeit bedingen
oder von ihm bedingt werden
das setzt uns sehr gehaltvolle zitat ein
sehr wichtiges zitat fangen mal ganz
hinten an inwiefern stehen diese
beziehung der identität und die
beziehung von zeit und raum
das ist natürlich beziehungen die fans
hängen die mit der kausalität relation
von vorsätzlichkeit und wirkung zusammen
vielleicht kann man das am besten klären
wenn sie jetzt mal nur auf die beziehung
von raum und zeit sich beziehen
wie hängt die beziehung von raum und
zeit mit der beziehung von ursache und
wirkung zusammen
inwiefern ist es mit der videos sagt
eine art von bedingungen oder ein in
einen bedingen verhältnis sicher steht
dieses verhältnis von raum und zeit in
einem verhältnis zum verhältnis von
chaos aus alten wirkung
die zeit irgendwelche
das ist richtig aber wie kann ich jetzt
über kausalität wie kann ich jetzt über
raum zeitliche verhältnisse auf
kausalität kommen also ich komme
vielleicht nicht direkt drauf aber wie
hängt das miteinander zusammen
warum ist kausalität mit raum und zeit
in einem verhältnis stehen genau als man
könnte sagen sie haben ganz recht mit
erfahrung also kausalität bedeutet dass
zwei gegenstände
was auch immer man sitzt ist dass die
raum zeitlich in einer erfahrungs
mäßigen wie sie richtig sagen nee stehen
das ist ganz entscheidend also das
betrifft jetzt endlich auch wieder die
frage nach der transit even relation von
ursache und wirkung
denken sie zurück an dieses gleich hab
sie nicht vergessen denken sie zurück an
dieses beispiel der dominosteine
das kann man jetzt also einen
dominostein also eine ganze reihe und
der erste dominostein wird umgekippt und
dann kippen alle anderen der reihe nach
auch um und jetzt kann man sich zur
dominokette natürlich noch mit anderen
entitäten vorstellen
denken sie mal sie ersetzen jetzt ein
dominostein durch ein gefühl der
schlechten laune oder durch einen
blitzeinschlag sie können es ja ganz
verschiedene entitäten anstelle der
dominosteine einsetzen und dann können
sie sich so eine geschichte überlegen wo
als eine erste ursache wie zum beispiel
ein blitzeinschlag die wirkung also die
ursache einer wirkung ist und die
wirkung können wir jetzt bestimmen
vielleicht also niemand an der blitz
schlägt jetzt hier ein
hier in dieses laptop und am ende kommen
bekommen am ende der kausalkette jetzt
gehen also ganz verschiedene kausal
aller die kausalkette geht jetzt davon
aus und am ende dieser kausalkette steht
jetzt das in amerika den usa in der
stadt chicago ein kleines kind schlechte
laune
so was könnte man jetzt sagen ist kausal
total ruhig gehen wir haben es da zwei
millionen zwischenschritte zwei
millionen kausale übergänge immer usa
wirken und am ende steht die schlechte
laune
dieses kindes und zwar 100 jahre später
100 jahre nach diesem blitz einschlagen
so und jetzt kann man sich fragen wie
sie da noch sagen dass dieser
blitzeinschlag ihren dieses gerät das
dazu führte dass ich in den laden ging
mir ein neues kaufte und promi sohn dann
kann man sich das so konstruieren dass
jetzt 100 jahren dann ein kind in
chicago
schlechte laune hat daher ein gefühl der
ein schlechtes gefühl hat was verursacht
wurde durch den blitzeinschlag
vermittelt durch zwei millionen zwischen
glieder und 100 jahren da haben wir
jetzt den fall dass wir raum und
zeitliche nähe nicht vorliegen haben in
diesem fall räumliche nähe nicht weil
das kind sich in chicago befindet das
ist für 1000 kilometer von hier entfernt
und zeitlich auch nicht weil es 100
jahre später ist das heißt wir sind wir
tendieren dazu und das ist eine sehr
sehr wichtige erkenntnis von david hume
für eine kausalität relation zur
bedingung zu machen dass differenz
zwischen zwei ereignissen er sagt jetzt
gegenständen ihr redet nur von
eindrücken dass die räumlich und
zeitlich sehr nah aufeinander sind also
da darf jetzt nicht groß eine woche
vergehen seinem idealfall sollte die
wirkung der ursache gleich passieren
und sie sollte auch in räumlicher nähe
passiert also jetzt nicht in chicago
sollen hier in diesem raum und jetzt
dachte man dass man von einem anderen
gesichtspunkt und das bestätigt jetzt
junges intuition weil überlegen sie mal
sie haben jetzt zwei ereignisse die
räumlich und zeitlich ziemlich nah
aufeinander folgen
da ist es ihnen bestimmt auch schon
häufig so gegangen dass sie dann
unterstellt hatten das ereignis sei die
ursache der wirkung des zweiten ereignis
gewesen aber es war am ende nicht so
sondern sie haben jetzt einfach sich
konstruiert aber die tore der faktum
dass beide ereignisse nahe beieinander
räumlich und zeitlich hat sie sagen
innerlich gezwungen schon fast das als
ein causales verhältnis zu deuten und
das ist eine sehr wichtige erkenntnis
von jung das also wenn wir raum
zeitliche nähe von zwei ereignissen
haben hat er ist kommt das ereignis und
dann kommt ein eigenes bild das wir dann
sofort mutmaßen dass diese zwei
ereignisse auf einander nicht einfach so
ab liefen als iris kammerer b sagen b
kam weil oder war die ursache von b und
das ist wie ich glaube sehr wichtiger
hinweis von zoom und ein weiterer
stichpunkte jetzt noch mal ein letzter
punkt zu diesem thema der transit von
kausalität relation philipp oebel ein
stuttgarter philosoph hat einen kurzen
text im internet finden den ich ihn
herum schicken kann von einer kausalen
ausgenommen gesprochen also die
ausbildung bedeutet die kausale kraft
von dem man irgendwie ausgeht die in der
ursache steht die durchsicht des eine
metapher die bühne sich irgendwann aus
und so weit aus dass wir gar nicht mehr
dann sagen würden dass sie die ursache
war von einem eigenes b weil so viel
zeit und so viel raum dazwischen die
also raum und zeit differenz sorgen
dafür dass sich kausalität ausdünnt wir
brauchen eine ziemlich stabile oder sehr
dicke relation und die dicke relation
von ursache und wirkung ist daneben
gegeben wenn sie sich in räumlicher und
zeitlicher nähe befinden das ist schon
mal ein hinein kriterium jeden fall
hatten sie sich gemeldet
wie gesagt war es für mich interessant
sagen dazu dann noch man sieht ist das
ja darum dass die zahlreichen langer
zeit passiert werden bedeuten würde das
wäre nicht nur noch direkt ausspricht
bleibt unklar
dadurch berufs oder vielleicht werden
kann
lecker denke nur durch direkte
kausalität das ist was auch die jetzt
das wort überstanden hätte bei der von
identität und stellen jetzt der punkt
war für uns gut ist über gegenstände zu
reden statt über eigenschaften
gegenständen sondern wir haben ihn zum
beispiel gegen eben schneller an sein
bein gebrochen haben und offenbar
verstehen müssen der bahn im ersten
moment und dann vorstellen
es ist aber wegen anderer sagt immer da
ist umschauen da wieder hin wenn es
zeitlich selbst unbemerkt bleiben von
der sekunde später zum anschauen und
auch das an der selbst stellen mehr als
zu klein für gold aber wenn eine seite
stellen ist alles diese kreativität und
dabei diese direkte kausalität gut also
ich haben jetzt noch richtig darauf
hingewiesen dass auch identität von
gegenständen dass auch die abhängt von
räumlicher und zeitlicher nähe wie sie
richtig sagen wir kommen in den raum
hinein
wir sehen ihren stühlen der mitte wir
gehen wieder raus und gehen wieder rein
und wenn er meter verschoben ist oder
ein paar zentimeter dann neigen wir
sofort dazu zu sagen es derselbe
derselbe stuhl wenn er jetzt aber
plötzlich woanders stehen ganz entfernt
ist haben wir schon probleme mit der
identität also jugend versucht jetzt
endlich verschiedene relationen relation
von identität das ist ja auch eine
zweistellige relation als a ist
identisch mit sich selbst
ja das ist identität sind zweistellig
relation und kausalität ist eine
zweistündige relation versuchte über die
relation von raum raum zeitlicher nähe
zu erklären
nur durch diese ja also jedenfalls
gesagt noch nicht direkt dass wir es
objektiv erkennen können er redet nur
von den bedingungen der möglichkeit von
kausalität erkenntnis das heißt damit
überhaupt kausalität möglich wird als
eindruck damit das phänomenal auftritt
dieser eindruck dass jetzt das in einem
verhältnis der kausalität ist müssen wir
voraussetzen dass ist raum zeitliche
sich befindet gut aber gutes beispiel
genau man würde jetzt normalerweise
annehmen erst blitzt und donnert wir
haben immer in der regelmäßigkeit immer
jeder menschen hat erstmal den blitz und
donner
in der regel ist immer die frage kann
man jetzt dieses dann an diesem bild
zuordnen ja wenn jetzt nur ein witz ist
aber eigentlich ist es ja so dass erst
der dollar ist und dann der blitze
donner braucht ebenso lang durch die
geschwindigkeit die ausbreitung in der
luft bis er ankommt akustisch bei uns
aber eigentlich ist ursächlich oder
zeitlich gesehen davor vor dem ereignis
plätzen
genau später aber weil wir eben uns in
einer genau pro kilo pro sekunde 1
kilometer irgendwie so sagt man ja weil
eben der der schall eine gewisse zeit
braucht bis er sich durchsetzt
sondern dann habe ich noch nicht
erreicht sein
der in dem sonst das die idee
es ist seit dem pausentee zum 1
ja also sie haben jetzt noch in weiteren
begriff also ins spiel gebracht mit dem
effekt dass sind praktisch die die
empirisch vorliegenden tatsachen
ein
ja also das denke ich muss noch mal
offen lassen sie sich genau damit
verhält das geht jetzt aus diesem zitat
nicht genau aber es gut dass ich darauf
hinweisen dass die die identitäts
relation dass man die frage aufwerfen
muss ob sie wie sie wie sie gefasst
werden muss ob sie als objekt gefasst
werden muss oder als ein ding vorgang
zeiten sie sich aber noch mehr
erstens war vielleicht unterscheidung
zwischen der gewinn und die herkunft der
anwendung dieses kann
sonja 200 für die grünen ein bisschen
andere
erklären deswegen zu schreiben man könne
sagen muss gewissen situationen wie das
entwickeln und dadurch ein zweiter
größerer wichtigkeit jordan ist daraus
dann die hand wenn man so zum beispiel
wieder flacher mieters aus regionaler
sicht sofort zeit nicht aufeinander sind
wir zum gehen soll
da kommt der begriff oder absolvieren
wird er ist und genutzt und dann durch
eine zusätzliche kommission wenden die
dann aber auch noch dinge an die
zeitlich und räumlich sehr weit
auseinander zb
münchen aber es scheint noch nicht klar
dass er über die anwendung ist noch
nicht gekommen noch drauf wir kommen
noch drauf es geht jetzt einfach um den
übergang vom eindruck auf eindruck b das
ist der entscheidende punkt jetzt hatten
sie sich aber noch gemeldet
eines aber eigentlich forderungen
verzichten
das ursächlich für bild und wenn man
aber dieser frau und seiner seite
ja das kann man seine methode ist die
schumann gibt ich glaube eher dass es
juristisch beschreibung ist wie wir
einfach kausalität wahrnehmen kausalität
anzunehmen bedeutet immer zu
unterstellen immer schon so zu denken
dass ursachen wirkung einfach in ihrer
empirischen qualität wenn sich überhaupt
als solche im touristisch wahrnehmen
lassen immer ein räumlicher und
zeitlicher nähe stehen dass das einfach
mit dazu gehört zu diesem vorgang
das finde ich aber eine ganz wichtige
beschreibung dass man sagt über raum und
zeitlichen nähe haben wir dass das finde
ich ist ein wichtiger hinweis trafen
also interessant ist nochmal hier das
also sagt jetzt wir können normalerweise
von einem sinnes eindruck wenn wir nur
einen zins eindruck haben können wir
eigentlich von diesem sinneseindruck auf
nichts anderes schließen die wahrnehmung
eines gegenstandes oder die das
vorliegen eines erkenntnis eines sinnes
geben standest du weißt nicht über sich
hinaus sagt er hier der geist kann bei
keinem derselben über das hinausgehen
was den sinn unmittelbar gegenwärtig ist
jetzt gibt es aber eine ausnahme sagt er
nämlich wenn wir einen eindruck haben
und von dem eindruck den eindruck
wiederum haben dass er die ursache eine
ursache sein
und dann können wir wenn wir erfahrungen
natürlich gemacht haben sagen ja immer
auf einen eindruck der altar folgt ein
eindruck der art b das heißt dann reicht
es ja eher zumachen und sagen dieser
eindruck weist insofern über sich hinaus
weil er nicht nur irgendein eindruck ist
sind wir jetzt als eindruck für uns
jedenfalls als eine art ursächlichkeit
gilt und diese ursächlichkeit in der
regel immer eine besondere wirkung zur
folge hat jedenfalls in der
vergangenheit immer hatte und daraus
schließe ich dass er irgendwie auch
jetzt noch diese wirkung mit sich
bringen muss also ursachen weisen immer
über sich hinaus und wirkungen weisen
hinter sich zurück das ist dieses
retrospektive dazu hatten sie sich noch
diese orte da haben sie völlig recht
haben
sie weisen dass sie weisen sehr zu recht
darauf hin dass das relativ ist
was heißt jetzt raum zeitliche ist
natürlich relativ was ist jetzt raumzeit
ich wie viel zeit darf jetzt zwischen
ursache und wirkung versprechen seien
zwei sekunden fünf sekunden eine gute
zehn minuten so und da kommt jetzt als
vorschlag der entität die situationen
spielt dann das ist der kundensituation
glaube ich kann ihren bedenken entgegen
kommen
ihre bedenken entkräften oder versuchen
zu entkräften indem sie sagt eine
situation ist eine konstellation von
raum zeitlichen verhältnissen die aber
in sich eine abgeschlossenheit haben dh
zu ursache und wirkung verhalten sich
wie verschiedene situationen die sich
räumlicher zeit erstrecken und in dieser
erstreckung ziemlich klare grenzen haben
man könnte auch sagen wie so eine art
geschichte wie so eine art eine
handlungs vollzog die handlung begann
hier und sie war hier abgeschlossen
die situation ist hier abgekapselt dass
jetzt die eine situation des der
entstehungskontext die ursächliche
kontext und die verursacht beim
zeitlichen raum zeitlichen
abgeschlossenheit eine andere situation
so könnte man es vielleicht vorstellen
situation sowieso nicht in der lage sein
das ist eine gewisse gleich der so
müsste man es genau
genauso müsste man es verstehen ja also
die diese dann die gesamtsituation von
ursache und wirkung und die
gesamtsituation ist eben räumlicher
zeitlich ausgestreckt es war dieser ort
wo die dieses sie setzen sagen die raum
zeitlichen enden die die situation die
gesamtsituation definieren und in der
situation geht es vielleicht immer zwei
situationen aber das ganze will eine
situation nach situation heißt es auch
situiert sein also räumlich und zeitlich
zu verorten sein dass also man könnte
jetzt eben mit dem begriff der situation
auf diese wahrheit zu sprechen kommen
[Musik]
das genau und hatte der kommilitone auch
schon gesagt ist vielleicht und ich
haben ein beispiel überlegt nämlich aus
dem hut bekommt von
seit jahren
ich denke man muss sich immer solche
beispiele überlegen das ist ganz wichtig
um es plausibel zu machen und sie haben
jetzt darauf hingewiesen wie fallen
könig die entitäten sein müssen
punktuell hörte dass die frage auch in
diesem standort artikel den ich ihnen
geschickt habe da tritt dann die frage
auf wie feinkörnig müssen ereignisse und
ursachen seien
haben sie eine ausdehnung ja oder liegen
sie nur punktuell sind ganz spannende
frage
[Musik]
caminada man sich jetzt bei uns
gleichzeitig stelle und ist ja richtig
endete der punkt der wahrscheinlichkeit
ist sehr wichtig nur ist ja eigentlich
nicht strengen begriff der mit
kausalität was zu tun hat also die
wahrscheinlichkeit begriff kommt dann
ins spiel wenn wir ein starkes konzept
von kausalität nicht mehr glauben
vertreten zu können
dann kommen die wahrscheinlichkeit rein
oder wenn wir zb starke
erkenntnistheoretische zweifel haben ob
wir überhaupt kausalität erkennen können
dann kommt sowas wie so ein
positivistischer begriff der
wahrscheinlichkeit ins spiel
aber eigentlich hat dieser begriff im
strengen sinne gar nichts mit qualität
zu tun da sind kommt erst dann ins spiel
wenn wir ins zweifeln geraten und es
objektivieren wollen bei der video
content spielt dann aber der
wahrscheinlichkeit begriff wiederum ist
sehr problematisch weil er eine
induktionsschleife unterlegt dass wir
eben von der gleichförmigen
gleichförmigen ereignissen der
vergangenheit auf die zukunft schließen
können das ist hoch problematisch da
müssen wir eine zusatzprämie noch mit
ins spiel nehmen nämlich dass ich die
vergangenheit sowie die zu unfällen und
das müssen wir nicht akzeptieren also
der wahrscheinlichkeit begriff macht die
sache glaube ihr noch komplizierter als
es sein ursprüngliches qualitätskonzept
mache oder bringt jedenfalls viele neue
schwierigkeiten mit sich mit sich auf
die auch jung eingeht aber so ein
wichtiger begriff den auch hier noch
berücksichtigen wird jetzt sagte
folgendes weiter in den gegenständen als
solches design wie sie wollen findet
sich nichts was uns überzeugen könnte
dass sie stets voneinander entfernt oder
sich stets beachtet sein müssten
und lehren uns erfahrung oder
beobachtungen dass ihre beziehungen in
dieser hinsicht unveränderlich sind zu
schließen wir stets das eine geheime
ursache bestehen welches sie trenne oder
vereinigen
das gleiche gilt rück sichtlich der
identität wir sind leicht bereit
anzunehmen ein gegenstand bleibt heiner
untersieben
auch wenn er immer wieder den sinn
entschwindet und denselben von 90
darstellt wir schreiben trotz der
unterbrechung der wahren identität zu
sobald überzeugt sind dass eine
unveränderliche unterbrochene warnung in
uns hervorgerufen hätte im falle wir mit
unseren blick oder unsere hand dauernd
festgehalten hätten also hier wird auch
identität jetzt über räumlich zeitliche
nähe definiert wie mir scheint also ganz
wichtig uns interessiert eben die
qualität sagte also sie müssen die nacht
seien dritte zeile uns lehrern
erfahrungen beobachtungen und lehren uns
erfahrung und beobachtung dass ihre
beziehung in dieser hinsicht
unveränderlich sehe zu schließen wir
stets das eine geheime ursache besteht
welches die trainer oder verhalten also
wie es wir werden genötigt wir werden
genötigt bei gewissen raum zeitlichen
stabilen verhältnissen von objekten
kausalität zu unterstellen ist also ein
entschluss der sich uns aufdrängt aber
dass kausale liegt nicht selbst in den
eindrücken selbst wenn sie nehmen jetzt
hier einen eindruck war wohl dem
eindruck selbst der eindruck sagt nicht
ich bin jetzt der eindruck der
kausalität ich bin eine kausalität
eindruck oder ich bin wirkungs eindruck
sie haben immer nur eindrücke und ob es
jetzt ein wirkungs eindruck oder eine
kausalität ein ursachen eindruck ist
dass ist dann abhängig von der
konstellation vor dem kontext innerhalb
dessen dieser eindruck auftritt die
konstellation ist natürlich eine
relation die selbst wiederum kein
eindruck ist eine relation ist kann
eindruck einer relation ist etwas was
zwischen eindrücken steht und vielleicht
auch etwas was wir selbst mit hinein
interpretieren
also da muss man unterscheiden wenn wir
sagen dass seine ursachen eindruck dann
beginnen wir ein fehler weil wir nämlich
die relation in der ursächlichkeit erst
auftreten kann
weil wir diese relation selbst in den
eindruck hinein produzieren oder
so ein bisschen ja also da wo ordnung
ist da wo regelmäßigkeit ist da wo ja
eben kein chaos ist da tendenziell da
ist da können wir auch ereignisse
verstehen und erklären nach dem prinzip
von ursachen wirkungen
da können wir sagen dass war die ursache
von dem unser sofort irgendwie
vielleicht auch kann man auch aber es
halt schwieriger vielleicht denn ja also
oder es gibt vielleicht auch so ein ganz
wie sich so ein klischee begriff und
chaos dazu sagt chaos ist einfach das
wenige was ich prinzipiell nicht
begreifen der ist könnte man unseren
begriffen entwickeln es gibt einfach ein
es gibt verhältnisse die sich nicht
verständlich machen lassen die wo wir
neue regeln finden die diese ursachen
oder diese ursachen darf gern ich sagen
diese verhältnisse erklärt und immer
wenn wir glauben wir haben die regel
dann tritt wieder beifall auf der nicht
an diese regel fällt und so kann man
sich natürlich kam uns auch vorstellen
okay aber das ist wirklich sagt noch mal
wichtig dieser dieser kontext diese über
die eindrücke unsere sinne hinausgehend
überzeugung dass der eindruck da ein
ursachen eindruck sei das ist ein
zusätzlicher überzeugung kann aber immer
nur auf dem bewusstsein einer kausalen
verknüpfung auf keine andere weise
können wir sicher sein dass der
gegenstand nicht inzwischen einem
anderen platz gemacht hat markt auch der
neue gegenstand dem früher den sinn
gegenwärtigen völlig gleichen wo wir
eine solche gleichheit bemerken erwägen
wir immer erst ob bei der betreffende
hart von gegenständen eine wirkliche
unterbrochene gleichheit mit sich oder
eine wirkliche unveränderte dauer
stattzufinden pflege oder nicht ob es
demnach möglich oder wahrscheinlich sei
dass irgendeine ursache bestehen die bei
solchen gegenständen ein wechsel oder
eine solche gleichheit oder unveränderte
dauer erzeuge und je nach dem entscheid
über das dasein solche ursachen um ihre
wirkung fällen wir unser urteil über die
identität des gegenstandes
also das ist glaube ich noch mal eine
wiederholung
es geht eben um raum zeitliche nähe und
die frage nach dem wechsel was sich dann
wiederum auf die frage nach der
identität von gegenständen auswirkt und
vor allem hier ist noch ganz wichtig und
zur urteil das fällen unseres urteils
über die identität also jung betrachtet
eigentlich gar nichts dass ihr jetzt die
welt wie sie ist und was deine bild ist
verbracht betrachtet die art und weise
wie wir über eindrücke urteilen als er
macht eigentlich fast schon so eine
sprach analytische untersuchung hier
das wird übrigens auch kant machen
immanuel kant der setzt auch nicht bei
den dingen in der welt wie sie da
vermeintlich existieren sondern kann
überlegt sich was machen wir eigentlich
wenn wir urteilen was machen wir dann
eigentlich dass selbst sein urteil
voraus ein urteil setzt immer voraus
dass wir gegenstände aufeinander
beziehen
als es zur sache von b wir beziehen
dinge aufeinander das ist ein urteil wir
haben ein subjekt und prädikat
gesprächen einem zug in ein prädikat zu
aber das ist ein kleiner exkurs
es zeigt sich also dass unter jenen drei
beziehungen identität raum zeitlichkeit
und kausalität die nicht lediglich von
der beschaffenheit der vorstellung
abhängig hängen die ursächlichkeit die
einzige ist die über unsere single
hinaus heißt und uns von existenzen und
gegenständen unterrichtet die wir nicht
sehen und tasten wir wollen uns darum
bemühen diese beziehung vollkommen klar
zulegen
die wir uns mit unserem thema der
untersuchung des verstandes abschließen
also die kausalität idee und der
eindruck der ist der einzige der für
eine beziehung der über sich hinaus
also ich habe hier diesen eindruck und
wenn ich glaube dass diese singles
eindruck ein ursächlicher
der eindruck eine ursächlichkeit sei und
in die erfahrung gemacht habe dass immer
wenn dieser eindruck war ein anderer
eindruck folgte dann antizipiere ich mit
dem bloßen auftreten des eindrucks immer
schon in anderen obwohl er noch gar
nicht da sein muss jedenfalls sagt
dieser eindruck mir dann der anderen
muss bald kommen also immer wenn ich
jetzt hier diesen ton höre dann
irgendwie fällt die lampe herunter
sie hören hier erschallt ein ton
ich weiß wie viel herz 440 hertz ein ton
und dann ein bisschen sand ton und dann
sehr springt diese diese neonröhre
und jetzt könnte man sagen die frequenz
dieses todes war die ursache dieses zu
springens dieser neonröhren und sie
machen die erfahrung ganz häufig immer
dieser ton ertönt und dann geht diese
neonröhren kaputt und das haben sie
jetzt 20 machen gemacht und jetzt hören
sie wieder diesen ton und dann
antizipieren sie in ihren geist wie die
neonröhre wieder kaputt geht und das ist
so dass dieser punkt dieses das
antizipieren das ist also wären
praktisch net' zitiert sie werden
genötigt indem sie diesen ton an diesen
ton bloß hören schon von diesem ton
überzugehen von diesem eindruck des
todes überzugehen
auf diesen visuellen eindruck dass jetzt
hier das licht ausgeht dieser ton der
impliziert schon fast das ausgehen des
lichtes obwohl sie nur diesen ton
sie haben nichts anderes ist haben nur
den ton und dann wird sie plötzlich zu
brechen
beschreibung deckt zur definition auf
die hat man die auch ihr allererstes zu
machen dass wir mit dem möglichen und
energien von morgen gesprochen haben und
öfter
aircraft oder der kraft klar dass er
jetzt zum beispiel geheime ursache
nennen oder um gegenstände oder das
fenster gegenständen die wir nicht sehen
und tasten können und so wie es scheint
das wäre quasi die kraft gerne denken
hatte dass das ihr kraft besonders wenn
wir postulieren das ist etwas was noch
nicht dass andere notwendig machen
werden schreibt man beobachten dass
nicht vor
und das führt natürlich wieder zurück
auf unseren denker der vorigen sitzung
aristoteles aristoteles spricht von der
potenz also dünner und das die potenz
ist die kraft der name ist genau so als
die potenz eines dinges oder eines
subjekts es könnte es tun dieses subjekt
könnte das tun das hat die möglichkeit
die potenz hat die kraft letztendlich
dazu und die kraft muss halt
verwirklicht werden
man muss halt der anlass dazu kommen
dann macht das ding auch das macht das
subjekt das aber es hat immer in sich
die kraft und david hume ganze
puristisch ganz positivistische sagt nee
nee nee so was wie eine kraft so die
potenz kann ich gar nicht annehmen da
bin ich als im puristischen oder er bis
zum logisch gut beraten der rede von
kräften oder von vermögen zu misstrauen
ich kann sie doch nicht wahrnehmen mit
kraft kann ich nicht wahrnehmen
die kraft muss ich immer realisieren
damit ich sie wahrnehmen kann aber jetzt
zu unterstellen dieses ding hat die
potenz das zu tun
das akzeptiert junge mit ihm das ist
eben dieses aristotelische denken dass
wir kräfte und vermögen er als solche
nicht mehr akzeptieren
bedingung war
eine gute frage da wirst du jetzt gerade
auch nichts also meines wissens hat jung
keine großen experimente gemacht hat
viele gedanken experimente gemacht da
ist es sehr gut in gedankenexperimente
aber jung war auch keiner chur forscher
obwohl er natürlich in dieser tradition
steht die dann auch schon mit newton
beginnt sofort ein bisschen aber david
hume war ein historiker david jung war
ein also ein historiker der hat auch
eine große bedeutende geschichte
englands geschrieben aber er war jetzt
kein physiker oder mathematiker wie es
minuten war aber ich glaube er steht im
geist dieser tradition weil newton auch
aristoteles see kritisiert also es geht
sie es geht darum in dieser zeit lassen
sich auch von aristoteles absetzt und so
was wie eine wirklichkeit bezweifelt und
auch so was wie ein vermögen als entität
zweifelt weil sich ein vermögen mp riss
tisch gar nicht quantitativ erschließen
ist wie soll denn ein vermögen was ich
nicht als solches irgendwie zeigt
sondern immer erst verwirklicht werden
muss wie soll ich denn ein vermögen
bitteschön empirisch mesz es geht doch
ganz oder
ja
ja wäre auch die wäre auch
positivistische gedachten also genau
richtig also wenn ich so eine kraft
messe dann habe ich da eben erst wie sie
richtig sagen die die die erscheinung
letztendlich oder die auswirkung einer
also letztendlich bekomme ich nie an die
die potenz heran
ich muss immer schauen wie wirkt sich
was aus und dann kann ich aufgrund der
wirkung vielleicht unterstellen dass da
so eine potenz ist oder sondervermögen
ist aber ein vermögen ist immer etwas
sehr sehr unter logisch voraussetzung
volles dass ich jetzt eine sache einem
menschen ein vermögen unterstelle das
sollte ich ihr vorsichtig sein das ist
wieder das prinzip des organischen
messers schreibt kann immerhin auch kein
war ein philosoph des mittelalters der
hat gesagt wir sollten zu wenig
entitäten zu wenig dinge annehmen wie
nur irgend nötig wenn wir damit ein
phänomen erklären können also wir
sollten versuchen um einen phänomen zu
erklären so wenig dinge anzusetzen mit
dem wir das phänomen erklären können wie
nur möglich
es sollte möglichst sparsam sein das
prinzip der unter logischen sparsamkeit
und diesem prinzip gehorcht auch der
visionär ist ganz sparsam sagt das was
wir haben ist nur sie nur eindrücke muss
indes eindruck und auf basis dieses
sinneseindrücke die uns unmittelbar
gegeben sind müssen wir alles bald
rekonstruieren und von diesen zins
eindrücken ausgehen müssen wir unsere
begriffe und kausalität die
notwendigkeit usw versuchen hier zu
meinen ja
er sagt ja das kann man sich später dass
identität auch nicht über sind also
wieso
regierung hatte er gebaut ist oder kann
man sagen es ist eigentlich
ursächlichkeit
deswegen ist es nicht was also wenn
mitmischen könnte ich so etwas gesagt
dass wenn sie mal eine weile nicht
gesehen haben genau also sie das
beispiel sie sehen hier genau
als ihm eindeutig dass der stuhl
insofern eigentlich auch über sich
hinausweist oder eindruck des stuhls
weil weil damit die in der identität
enthalten ist er wird derselbe sein auch
wenn ich nicht okay dann fassen sie das
wie er war als einen anderen gegenstand
auf also da sind sie mit jungen tag aber
you meint eben etwas anderes als sie
müssten jetzt von dem stuhl auf einen
anderen stuhl schließen
sie schließen die jetzt vom stuhl auf
den stuhl ist schon richtig weil
natürlich identität mit zweistellige
relation ist also das ist identität der
säbel
aber sie haben jetzt bei kausalität eben
was anderes hier
und das meint jetzt eben jung dass sie
auch was anderes schließt ja er meint
eben wahrscheinlich dass also vielleicht
auch so was wie das man sagt da ist
jetzt so eine kausale kraft am werk das
würden sie bei dem stuhl nicht sagen
dass der sturm mit sich identisch bleibt
dazu braucht er keine kausale kraft
ja richtig als identität da geht es auch
noch um was es eigentlich schon über
sich hinaus in einer gewissen weise weil
es eben eine zweistellige relation des
up ist insofern nicht über sich hinaus
weil es halt wieder ist es derselbe typ
und bei der kausalität redaktion weiß
deshalb auf den anderen gegenstand hin
und eben auch noch auf einen anderen
modus nämlich auf den modus dass all
seine kraft ist wie so eine
notwendigkeit
[Musik]
andere
eine komplexe perzeption ca ja genau als
haus aufpassen bei der rede von
gegenstand also von objekten also der
stuhl ist nach jung nicht so ein sondern
ist ein homogener eindruck sind der
stuhl ist eine komplexe perzeption
welche aktion spricht von eindrücken
auch von konzeptionen das heißt einfach
nur wahrnehmungs gegenstimmen
das wenige was wahrgenommen wird und das
kann eben in der aller schlichtesten
form eben auch gegenstand genannt werden
zum beispiel ein völlig homogen roth
eindruck sie haben jetzt nur rot fahrung
und zwar nicht rot mit einer orangenen
schattierung sondern nur rot und das
gesamte gesichtsfeld sei jetzt aus einem
rot ton bestehen haben sie in diesem
moment eine minimale eine basale
perzeption von roth dieses bestimmten
typs von roth wurde sie hören einen sehr
homogenen klang mit der frequenz 440
herz ganz präzise haben sie auch einen
total homogen akustischen eindruck wenn
sie jetzt den stuhl sehen haben sie
nicht nur einen homogenen eindruck
sondern sie haben verschiedene einträgen
sie haben etwas gelb aber auch diese
maserung des holzes dieter abgebildet
ist ist nicht homogen
sie haben gelb orange töne sie haben wir
noch einen silber ton und wenn sie ihn
anfassen ist es nur hart sie haben also
den stuhl können sie beschreiben durch
die menge von verschiedenen perzeption
'nen und das meint yu mit der komplexen
rezeption also ein stuhl wäre sagen eine
menge so eine menge klammern müssen sie
dann machen und dann müssen sie hier
verschenkt ziemliche qualitäten eintrag
die gesamten gelbtöne die sie sehen also
eine farbtöne alle visuellen eindrücke
alle optischen eindrücke und sowie halt
der stuhl sich sinnlich ihn überhaupt
darbieten kann und dann haben sie auch
das problem wenn sie auf eine andere
eine andere richtung gehen hat sich der
stuhl schon wieder ganz anders aus dann
kann man sich fragen ist derselbe stuhl
aber sieht doch jetzt anders aus bin
jetzt da hingegangen jetzt sieht es
wieder anders aus das ist das derselbe
stuhl sie doch völlig verschieden aus
und es ist auch ein riesenproblem
verfügung wir auf basis dieser bloßen
perzeption sowas wie gegenständlichkeit
eben anzeigen kann
ich müsste es jedes mal wenn ich diesen
stuhl aus einer anderen perspektive
betrachten müsste da ein neues ding sein
und etwas anderes sein
und jetzt kommt wieder neue
sinneseindruck hinzu jetzt ist ein
riesenproblem für david hume ich mach
mal gerade weiter noch um in der ordnung
zu beginnen müssen wir dabei zunächst
die vorstellung der ursächlichkeit
selbst ins auge fassen und zu sehen
woher sie stammt es ist unmöglich
richtig zu denken jemand die vorstellung
die den gegenstand des denkens bild.de
vor vollkommen versteht und es ist
unmöglich irgendeine vorstellung
vollkommen zu verstehen ohne dass man
sie bis zu ihrem ursprung verfolgt und
den ursprünglichen eindruck prüft dem
sie entstand es geht um die vorstellung
der ursächlichkeit die untersuchung des
eindrucks bringt klarheit in die
vorstellung und die untersuchung der
vorstellung bringt in gleicher weise
klarheit in das denken also wir haben
jetzt hier eindrücke vorstellung und
hier denken wir müssen also um die
vorstellung zu erklären zurück auf den
eindruck den um die vorstellung zu
erklären müssen wir die vorstellung und
die einträge sind die dass die
unmittelbare basis das ist das was wir
unmittelbar vor fehlen uns die eindrücke
als rot eindruck usw
hinter die können wir nicht mehr
zurückgehen dass damit fangen wir dass
unser material mit dem wir aufbauen und
dann abstrahieren wir davon ein
schwaches abbild des alltags wir
erinnern uns daran dass wird
abgespeichert sein schwache abtastung in
unserem geist und über das können wir
dann noch mal denken sagt jun
okay dass die methode das ist die
methode wir das macht das ist
letztendlich die empirische methoden wir
müssen unsere begriffe zb kausalität
wäre zu denken kausalität dass der
begriff unser denken oder ursächlichkeit
müssen wir zurückführen auf vorstellung
und die müssen wir dann zurück firmen
können auf eine ursache das ist auch
eine nennt man auch eine empirische
bedeutungs theorie um die bedeutung von
kausalität zu verstehen müssen wir erst
die vorstellung
die mit diesem begriff einhergehen und
von den vorstellungen müssen wir
wiederum auf die ursprünglichen wurzeln
zurück gehen
die diese vorstellung und jetzt kann man
sich fragen was machen sie mit dem
vorstellung haben sie die vorstellung
erzeugt sind die einträge ursachen der
vorstellung dann legen wir gerade diesen
begriff wieder zu gründen
wir wollen kausalität erklären erkläre
ihnen aber eigentlich schon mit
kausalität in dem dieses verhältnis
kausal gedacht wird ganz problematische
kommt auch bei der video ist es nicht
zirkulieren bin ich jetzt gerade presto
willkommen aber das ist jedenfalls die
methoden im puristischen methode richten
wir also unser augenmerk auf zwei
beliebige gegenstände die wir bzw
als ursache und wirkung bezeichnet
wenn wir sie nach allen seiten um jenen
eindruck zu finden der eine vorstellung
von solch ungeheurer tragweite
hervorrufen kann auf den ersten blick
sehe ich dass ich den selben nicht in
irgend einer bestimmten eigenschaften
gegenstände suchen
denn welche diese eigenschaften auch ich
heraus greife immer finde ich ein
gegenstand der sie nicht besitzt und
doch gleichfalls gelegentlich von uns
als ursache oder wirkung bezeichnet wird
in der tat gibt es ja nichts was
existiert außer uns oder in uns das
nicht entweder als ursache oder als
wirkung eines anderen angesehen würden
müsste dagegen gibt es offenbar keine
eigenschaft die allem existierenden
gemeint wäre und das recht mit solchen
namen bezeichnet zu werden geben könnte
also das problem ist versucht jetzt er
hat jetzt den eindruck zum beispiel brot
eindruck oder den einst den ton den ich
jetzt hier oft genannt habe dieses 44
herz tun und das haben wir den eindruck
440 hertz auch wir müssen auch immer nur
auch immer die die die sinnliche seite
also die phänomenale seite betrachten
wie es eben ist ein ton zu hören
sie hören den ton sie gehen ganz dem
hören des tons auf und in diesen höhen
des tones ist nicht mehr informationen
enthalten als dass sie diesen ton hören
und zwar so wie sie in hören diese
subjektive weise wie es eben ist 440
herz zu hören von ihrem jeweiligen uhr
das mag auch unterschiedlich sein jemand
von ihnen sieben mögen unterschiedlich
hier phänomenale wahrnehmung von 440
herz haben ich stelle hier in der mitte
des raumes ein lautsprecher auf und
erzeuge einen ton mit 440 herz dann wird
natürlich jeder von ihnen die 440 hertz
anders hören
das ist ganz klar ich weiß nicht wie es
ist wie sie 140 herz hören dass mut das
weiß nur jeder von ihnen zählt ja wie es
jetzt aber dass sie irgendwas hören das
ist klar und vision und das ist dann der
der eindruck ist frage gibt uns dieser
eindruck irgendwelche informationen
darüber ob er kann saal wirksam als ob
darin die ursächlichkeit gelegen ist und
dass die spannende frage und da muss man
sehr sehr skeptisch seien deswegen sagt
auch junge folgenden seite hat die
vorstellung der ursächlichkeit muss also
irgendeiner beziehung zwischen den
gegenständen entnommen zahlen zwischen
den eindruck als seien die gegner
dabei finde ich in erster linie dass
gegenstände welche als ursachen bzw
wirkungen einander betrachtet werden
zeit räumlich mit diesen unmittelbar
zusammenhängen dass nichts in einem ort
oder zeitpunkt wirken kann
der sei es auch noch so wenig von dem
ort unter zeitpunkt entfernt wäre
in dem es sich befindet wenn wir es auch
bis wenn es auch bisweilen so scheint
als ob entfernte gegenstand
daher vorbrächten so findet man doch bei
näherer untersuchung jedes mal dass sie
durch eine kette von ursachen verbunden
sind welche untereinander und mit den
voneinander entfernten gegenständen
räumlich unmittelbar zusammenhängen und
wenn wir in einem bestimmten fall diesem
zusammenhang nichts entdecken können zu
nehmen wir doch an dass er vorhanden
sein
wir können also die beziehung der
kontinuität dh der angrenzend hide als
wesentlich für die beziehung der
ursächlichkeit betrachten wir dürfen
dies wenigstens in übereinstimmung mit
der allgemeinen meinung so lange tun bis
ich eine passende gelegenheit ergibt die
sache um die es sich hier handelt
dadurch aufzuhellen dass wir untersuchen
welche gegen stellt das nebeneinander
oder der heimischen verbindung fähig
sind und welche nicht als die
kontinuität bedeutet einfach nur
angrenzend halt raum zeitliche nähe als
sein argument ist jetzt wenn wir jetzt
sagen hier gibt es entfernte sachen weil
es dann das argument das argument ist
die transit ivi tät der kausalität
relation also ich schließe jetzt aus
diesem zitat sie können wir gerne wieder
sprechen dass er von einer transit ivi
tät ausgeben wenn es sagt letztendlich
auch wenn die wirkung noch so weit
entfernt ist dann ist es eigentlich
nicht die richtige die ursprüngliche
wirkung sonst eine entfernte wirkung die
nur deswegen wirkung genannt werden kann
weil da eben ganz viele kleine kapsel
schritte dazwischen sind und die muss
ich jetzt eben zurückgehen bis auf den
ersten schritt dieses ersten
dominosteins als zweiter der dann
umgefallen ist der erste streifen der
stand ist die ursache und der zweit ist
unmittelbare wirkung und so muss ich
eben durchgehen und wenn ich eben
schauen zwei dominosteine ja dann ist
das szenario aber jetzt überlege ich mir
gerade bei der gelegenheit hätten jetzt
ein dominostein der ist ein kilometer
hoch und einen anderen dominosteine der
ist 800 meter daneben gelegen gut dann
kippt er eine und trifft den dann würde
man aber dennoch sagen es ist raum
zeitlich nahe weil
selbst wenn der ein kilometer im fernen
ort acht meter entfernt steht ja erst
dann kausal einwirkt wenn er den zweiten
direkt trifft als auch damals an die
raum zeitliche nähe haben sich sie genau
ich erzeugt irgendwie kausal auch
auswirkungen auf die luftmoleküle und da
haben wir so kleine kausalität ketten in
den luftmolekülen die dann irgendwann in
ihrem urlaub
berührend ja es muss direkt muss direkt
angrenzend sein also sehr konkrete
vorstellung genommen sie haben
da habe ich immer das ist ja die frage
nach der identität ist ja auch spannend
wobei ja gar nicht diese so stark ins
zentrum stellt es geht im jahr
er sagte nur identität ist eine relation
die es geben kann aber und kausalität
ist eben so verfasst dass sie zwei
verschiedene gegenstände miteinander in
beziehung gesetzt werden
natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen ist
jetzt in dem die ursache von bse ist
damit auch ein identitäts aussage
getätigt die frage jedenfalls spielt
hier raum zeitliche anknüpfung an
grenzen teilt die große rolle
[Musik]
diese
ja wir werden eben häufig auch zu
fehlschlüssen verurteilt praktisch
verleitet ja wenn wir pauschal denken
wir sind so strukturiert dass wir immer
glauben wenn etwas erst war und das
andere dann war das das erste die
ursache war das zweite ist die wirkung
und so können wir uns täuschen darin
dass eben die der der ton der donner
dass der eigentlich nicht die wirkung
ist sollen zwei auch nicht die ursache
jedenfalls zeitlich davor warnen oder
gleich ganz genau
und das ist so auch so ein bisschen die
sind am ende der heutigen sitzung und
sind auch jetzt gut vorangekommen wir
müssen ein paar weiteren seiten lesen
haben das ist auch so die porsche bei
der emission dazu sagt wir haben uns die
tendenz immer davon auszugehen wenn zwei
ereignisse regelmäßig aufeinander
folgten sie als ursächlich anzunehmen
wir machen häufig die erfahrung dass auf
ein ereignis des typs a
ein ereignis des typs b folgt immer
dieser ton dann geht das licht aus ton
das licht aus ton das licht aus wenn man
das häufig gemacht haben sind irgendwann
in einer gewissen erwartungshaltung und
diese erwartungshaltung nötigt uns
diesen ersten eindruck
eine zusätzliche qualität zuzusprechen
nämlich die der ursächlichkeit und da
sagt jetzt natürlich jung wenn man das
jetzt streng betrachten können wir nicht
gar nicht von wirklicher strenger
notwendigkeit sprechen weil das ist nur
das subjektive disposition die
kausalität annahme ist etwas was wir
selbst mit hineinbringen durch gewöhnung
die kausalität selbst existiert so nicht
nur das ist etwas was wir leisten und es
könnte genauso sein dass irgendwann mal
die 440 hertz erklingen und das licht
nicht ausgeht ja habe ich ein
fehlschluss begangen das heißt ich
machen induktions schluss mit der du
dich induzieren von einer ähnlichen
anzahl von vergangenen ereignissen
schließlich darauf dass es auch in der
zukunft immer so sein wird und dieser
schluss ist problematisch dass eine
zusatz an
die nicht in der information dieser
phänomenalen qualitäten dient uns durch
die sinne vermitteln sind enthalten ist
das ist so ein bisschen jetzt die pointe
von der vision also wir werden im
nächsten sitzung da noch ein bisschen
weiter lesen und dann auch auf manuell
kant zu sprechen kommen der sei die
kausalität theorien ganz ganz intensive
auseinandersetzung mit der
herausforderung durch david hume
entwickelt also sie wissen ja kann sagt
es sei es ein dogmatischer schlummer
geweckt worden durch david hume also
kann versucht jetzt folgendes zu machen
versucht zu sagen
wie können wir die objektivität der
qualitäts relation sicherstellen
die stimmung nicht sicherstellen konnte
selbst wenn wir jungen darin recht geben
dass wir von unserer erfahrung anheben
müssen wie kann sagt um überhaupt
erkenntnis zu haben
wie können wir dennoch trotz aller
zweifel scroll edition anführt so was
wie kausalität objektiv annehmen selbst
wenn sich in den erfahrungs eindrücken
selbst so was wie eine kausale
information nicht finden und das wird
dann darauf hinauslaufen dass kanzler
wir selbst wir erkennen den subjekte wir
leisten die objektivität der kausalität
nicht nur subjektiv wie es jung annimmt
sei eben verbinden und das wird die
spannende frage sein wie sowas oder ob
so was überhaupt dann bis zur nächsten
sitzung